تي آر باري هو نائب الرئيس التنفيذي في
معهد كويني لفن
الحكم المسؤول، وهو مؤلف كتاب خسارة
العدو أوباما إيران وانتصار
الدبلوماسية، وينضم إلينا من
واشنطن العاصمة، ومن دواعي سرورنا أن تكون معنا في
الكثير من مؤتمرات القمة التي تعقد
الآن  وبالنسبة للأشخاص الذين يحاولون فك رموز
ما تعنيه هذه اللحظة بالذات، ما
مدى أهمية حضور الرئيس الإيراني
شخصيا في الرياض؟ ما الذي
ستوليه أكبر قدر من الاهتمام لأنه
مهم للغاية لأنه مر
بعض الوقت منذ أن قام
رئيس إيراني بزيارة المملكة العربية السعودية  وبالطبع
كان البلدان
على خلاف عميق مع بعضهما البعض على مدار
العامين الماضيين، وكان هناك
القليل من RMA في العام الماضي فقط أو
جزئيًا بفضل دبلوماسية الصين،
وسيكون من المثير للاهتمام معرفة ما إذا كان أه
سيجتمع ولي العهد السعودي الأمير محمدين سلمان وRI في الكاميرات وهما
يتصافحان وما إلى ذلك،
ويمكن أن تصبح هذه الصور في نهاية المطاف رمزية تمامًا
لما تعنيه هذه اللحظة من حيث كيفية
اقتراب السعودية وإيران من بعضهما
البعض.  أيها المشاهدون، كما
تعلمون في برود، العلاقة الإيرانية السعودية
من حيث
القيادة الإقليمية والحرب الحالية، وعلاقات إيران
مع السعودية، فإن
عملية التطبيع المبدئية التي
كانت جارية هي تسوية العلاقة
من خلال ما يحدث في المنطقة
الآن بالتأكيد  يعقد تلك
العلاقة من ناحية،
هاتان الدولتان تدعيان القيادة
في العالم الإسلامي الأوسع أه
الإيرانيون يحاولون ادعاء
تلك القيادة من خلال معارضة
اتخاذ الولايات المتحدة موقفًا أكثر قسوة
فيزا إسرائيل المملكة العربية السعودية ادعت
أن القيادة شريكة  لأنها
موطن الإسلام أه تحالفها مع
الولايات المتحدة وهذه الأشياء
تظهر أه أه على السطح
الآن لأنني أعتقد من وجهة نظر مكتب الإحصاء
أنه من الخطر بعض الشيء بالنسبة
له الآن أن يكون له صوت سلبي للغاية
في القضايا الفلسطينية لأنه
يخشى أن
يزرع قيادة تلك القضية لإيران
أو لتركيا أه أردوغان قائد آخر أه
في المنطقة
يدعي القيادة أيضا أم لنتحدث عن
أه الولايات المتحدة واستراتيجية
الردع الخاصة بها  يبدو
منذ البداية أنه تم التركيز على
إيران وحزب الله، هل نجح في تنفيذ
استراتيجية الاحتواء، وهل اختفى خطر
التصعيد الإقليمي،
ولم يختف خطر التصعيد على الإطلاق
في نفس الوقت الذي لم نقم فيه بذلك؟  رأيت
درجة التصعيد أه التي يمكن أن
تؤدي إلى حرب أوسع الآن سواء
كان ذلك بسبب الردع الذي تضعه الولايات المتحدة
من خلال نقل المزيد من
القوات إلى هناك أو سواء كان ذلك لأنه
في نهاية المطاف لا حزب الله
ولا إيران يريدان فعلاً  حرب كبرى
غير واضحة في هذه المرحلة